[Music]
before my 30 years old I'm a failure
people lose by never give up just start
apply the 595 rule it will change your
life
rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
what's up believe nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message never give up
over to you Jack Ma also if you want to
build unstoppable confidence like Jack
Ma and other successful entrepreneurs
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next two hundred
and fifty four days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is an
inscription below the people who do the
bottom should believe in the model and I
believe what I do as a young boy I never
thought you know it's a young boy if
ever today I never thought I would be
here honestly I never thought but as a
young boy I probably when I look back
every problems I met him by when I was a
kid benefited me I filled so many times
people probably know that I've applied
jobs for so many jobs over 30 jobs all
rejected not even got a chance 24 of us
were interview for a KFC job 23 accepted
I was the only guy rejected by six
people went full of looking for a police
job five except I was the only one my
cousin I applied job as a as a as a
server in a full style to my city we
waited long queue for two hours he was
accepted I really so my mother looked at
me huh
yeah you know yes but I know this is a
training course for me before my thirty
years old I'm a failure all people lose
by never give up I think there is
opportunity there and then I I was a
teacher later I read from University I
was teaching in the university for six
years number five because number five
year I was elected the best a teacher of
my universe elected by students
so I said everything I taught my
students are the things I learned from
books what if I go out spend a 10 years
experience all the things whether fail
or succeed I'd go back to teach again
that was my original thing in doing
Alibaba so I never thought I could be
rich I never thought it would be
successful I never thought we could
survive for 18 years and then we made it
you are losing because you spend too
much time planning and not enough time
doing apply the 595 rule spend five
percent of your time planning 95 percent
of your time doing apply it it will
change your life
you see you're worried about having the
perfect plan and then rethinking that
plan and rejigging that plan and
researching that plan all over again and
thinking and tweaking and testing that
plan meanwhile Jack Ma is out there
executing on his ideas changing his plan
multiple times and becoming rich in the
process if you don't start doing more if
you don't start applying the 595 rule
you will dream up countless perfect
business plans on your couch meanwhile
people like Jack Ma will be out there
executing them I'm a recovering
perfectionist I lost when I was 22 years
old a 40 million dollar deal because I
was a perfectionist because I spent the
entire summer working on the perfect
business model the perfect business plan
and I missed the opportunity that was
right in front of me because it didn't
take enough action and that's what
drives me forward now when I get an idea
I go off and do if you can shorten the
gap between idea and do
idea and action idea and do idea in
action that will set you up for success
for life I care so much about it
personally because I lost a 40 million
dollar deal and that's really painful
and I don't want that to happen to you I
don't want you to lose a big opportunity
in your life because you spent too much
time planning and hemming and hawing and
thinking about it instead of just going
out and doing the thing so now when I
get an idea I commit to it and I just
start doing it instead of finding what a
big huge version of this will be I dumb
it down to what's the smallest possible
way to get started so when I was looking
at creating my new Instagram live show
in the morning and at Toronto dancehall
so I just started on Friday night I'm
coming home from Los Angeles Friday
night I'm gonna start doing this I'm
gonna start an Instagram morning show I
had to reject everybody's schedules
people who normally meet me I don't have
two hours randomly at the start of every
single day for this show and so I'm
emailing people on my team so that I'm
committed to doing it I'm emailing
people who could be my first guest so
I'm committed to doing it and one of the
people on my team wrote back this is a
Friday night he writes back to say
awesome everyone are we starting Monday
that's how we do it you get an idea we
start right it's Friday night midnight
as five days a week we start Monday we
start it's gonna suck and we start right
we're gonna start at the beginning we're
gonna make lots of mistakes on my first
Instagram live show I didn't have a
microphone and I was sitting across the
room from my camera and people are
complaining hey we love the energy but
we can't hear you great awesome go buy
microphone next episodes are better and
as we get better and as we scale up
maybe becomes as big huge production
maybe it's the next greatest thing of
all time for me and I stopped doing
YouTube videos and it's only gonna be
Instagram live videos or maybe the whole
thing fizzles out I committed to do it
until December and maybe after that I
don't care about it anymore and I drop
it either way I won't know until I go
out and do I can't sit on my couch and
plan and research and rejigged and think
my way to solving that problem the only
way to know is to get out there and
actually do and while most people are
thinking and planning and questioning
and coming up with excuses and reasons
why they can't do it I'm off they're
doing I don't think that I'm that
naturally special talented or gifted my
youtube channel I sucked as a speaker go
back and look at
my first video is on how long the
journey is taken me I'm I'm 6,000 videos
in like you better get good at something
6000 videos in but I stuck with it and I
just started and that's what I want you
to do just start apply the 595 rule it
will change your life 5% of your time
planning 95% of your time doing now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
question today I want to know how can
you apply the 595 rule to your life or
business what's a single biggest impact
you can see it making for you I'd love
to hear from you put it in the comments
below
never give up on what you really want to
do the person with big dreams is more
powerful than the person with all the
facts H Jackson Browne
truer words have never been spoken it is
one of the most interesting things about
the human condition
that all of the facts in the world no
matter how true something may
objectively really be the only thing
that matters is whether or not you've
got the energy to see through to the end
of what you want to do and the energy
comes not from truth the energy comes
from your dream the energy comes from
what it is that you want to do the
energy ultimately is born out of what
you want to create it's born out of a
willingness to allow yourself to dream
it's born out of a willingness to think
that you actually can do it it's born
out of a willingness to take that first
step but the only reason that you're
gonna take that first step is you
believe that you can actually make your
dreams come true and that sense of this
thing that you have in your mind that
you can make it real that you can bring
it into the real world and have that
excitement you've long fantasized about
and understand and really feel in your
gut that that thing that you've dreamed
about can be real and when you have that
that's when you're going to have the
energy that you need to push and to
fight and to go through all of the
difficult things you're gonna have to to
get on the other side and make that
dream real as Ferdinand Foxx said the
most powerful weapon on earth is the
human soul on fire the
can't be on fire without a dream a human
soul is not fed by facts a human soul is
fed instead by a belief that it can
accomplish what it wants to accomplish
it's fed by that thing that idea that
you found your mind that you fan those
flames of interest and turned it into a
real fascination and fan those flames
further into excitement and allowed
yourself to truly embody that belief
that you can make it happen so right now
whatever it is whatever crazy dream you
have and we all have one stop judging
yourself for it stop telling yourself
that you can't do it and understand when
you cultivate that fire when you take
that little ember and you fan it into a
raging inferno that that thing that
human stole on fire is what's going to
allow you to build something that the
world has never seen before but it
starts with that dream it starts with
your willingness to cultivate that to
think about it to allow yourself to do
that because so many people stop
themselves they think they're inadequate
they think that they could never do it
and even if that is a fact
it's not something that's gonna help you
live a life that excites you it's not
something that's going to help you
excite other people but one thing that
will do that is the dream so right now
allow yourself that simply to dream if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would become like a little beacon
if you want some more Jack Ma motivation
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there it was so
difficult at that time I was so
frustrated I taught in the university my
pay was ten dollars a mouth